hey it's justine and today we're
unboxing the gold iphone 12 pro max
and the product red 12 mini
[Music]
we've now got both of them unboxed and i
know we were recording b-roll and really
cool cinematic shots but i about lost my
mind when i
opened up both of these because they are
such a stark contrast of each other we
have this 12 pro max
up against this 12 mini can we just take
a quick second to do a little size
comparison
because this is a sight to be seen
[Music]
here's the fronts of the screens it's
kind of wild just looking at this pro
max
because the size comparison the actual
physical size of this phone
is not much larger than the 11 pro max
they were able to extend the screen
slightly because of the way that this
now was designed the edges are all flat
and the bezels are slightly smaller so
it does give you just a little bit more
screen but when you're holding it
it does feel about the same size as the
11 pro max
but it has a much easier hold because
the edges aren't rounded
i don't feel like it's going to slip out
of my hand and now the
mini can we take a moment just
to look at how small this is i
don't have very large hands so this is
kind of crazy that i can just pick it up
just like this
in comparison to the 12 pro max i mean
what what now let's get our entire 12
lineup for 2020 all lined up 12
mini is going smudgy so what are the
differences
the iphone 12 and the iphone 12 mini are
basically the same phone the 12 mini
does have a slightly smaller battery so
you won't have as good of battery life
as the 12 as for the 12 pro and the 12
pro max
are almost identical except for two
things the telephoto and the wide angle
lens
in the 12 pro max it has a 65 millimeter
telephoto lens whereas the 12 pro only
has 52. you can also optically zoom in
2x for an even closer shot
the sensor on the pro max is 47 larger
than the 12 pro
and it also has sensor shift technology
which is allowing for enhanced image
stabilization
so the actual sensor is doing the
stabilization as opposed to the lens
itself
so here you have them we've got the mint
green the gold the pacific blue and the
product
red now the colors this year are a
little bit more of a muted tone as
opposed to some previous years i
love the mint and i am honestly very
shocked at the gold now when i first saw
this gold in the keynote
i thought it was gonna be more of like
an obnoxious gold
like a very yellowy sort of loud really
it is a very
subtle nice gold color i absolutely love
it but wow
fingerprints i mean let's be real
i'm probably never gonna actually take
this out of a case so the gold
i really like it don't even know which
color i'm going to end up pre-ordering
as my personal phone
thank the white but then i like the gold
but then the graphite will match my
watch
and then the blue is also really pretty
now that brings us to the red color
product red i do have to say i think
that this is the least
red product red item that i have ever
seen
and that's not a bad thing kind of seems
like it's more
pinkish either way i was pleasantly
surprised with this color i actually
really really like it and
the feel of this mini phone times like
this
where i wish that i didn't want to have
the
best top of the line iphone because
this mini it's perfect like the screen
looks amazing
i really like it a lot it's so precious
so i'm sure if you guys are avid iphone
users you probably have seen all the
colors at some point across
all of the multiple youtube channels and
people reviewing these and i'm just
wondering what is your favorite iphone
color of 2020 leave that in the comments
below and i'll feature some of your
comments in the next video biggest
upgrade in the pro versions
is you do have three lenses and they
also have the lidar scanner
whereas the 12s only have the two lenses
no telephoto or lidar but what's really
amazing is the fact that the 2020 iphone
lineup is
pretty impressive all around i feel like
whichever phone you pick
like you can't go wrong obviously the 12
pro max has some upgrades but i do love
the size of the 12 pro
installs the extra lens it has a lidar
scanner and i've been so impressed with
it over the past few weeks that i've
been using it so you guys know that i
will have plenty of follow-up videos if
you guys aren't subscribed please hit
subscribe
and be sure to hit the bell as well so
you'll be notified when i post a new
video
but now we have a few accessories of
course
magsafe each phone is equipped with
magnetic back so
does anybody remember that game i think
that it was called go fish and you had a
little fishing pole and there were
little fish in the pond that had
magnetic mouths anyway that's what i
feel like i'm doing right now
wow pro max heavy
still holding it up though
so the pro versions are made of
stainless steel around the edges
and the 12s are aluminum so they are
slightly lighter of course we know it's
no secret that there is no
charging brick in the box for any of
these devices this year and yes i know
it's been
a meme and a real hot topic but you guys
all know that
every other phone carrier is probably
going to follow suit so do
with that information what you will
accessories
so i already opened this before this is
the magnetic
wallet backing so let's see what that
looks like on the mini
it fits actually wow it fits perfectly
on the mini anytime you place anything
magnetic from apple it will give you a
little
signal there to let you know that it's
attached
we also have the 12 pro max this is the
leather case
so here it is so you've got the little
outline
where the magnet resides and let's just
pop this
in there it is
and it matches the color of the case oh
these colors look nice together
wow wow wow
i'm just really shocked at how much i
love this gold color wow
wow the one accessory that i'm really
excited to test out is they have this
like foldable little charger so you can
charge your apple watch and then you can
also charge your phone on the other side
this thing looks super cool next up we
have the iphone 12 mini leather sleeve
this is cool because it has like this
little wrist strap oh look at that
this is very interesting it's got the
little camera bump
cut out this should automatically change
the color of the time to match the
leather case when you put it in there
oh you did it wow that's cool
it even has like a little pocket right
here so you can put a credit card
this is nice this might be a cute
bracelet okay well it doesn't
quite fit here's the directions
look at that that's actually very nice
i just love that the clock in the
background changes colors
to match whatever case you have on it so
the mini in comparison to
the new iphone se is as follows
you can tell that the mini is slightly
smaller you actually
have much more screen real estate on the
mini than you do
on the se because of the lack of the
bezels but what you do get on the sc
is that good old-fashioned touch id
probably going to be next year that
apple will be able to integrate touch id
back
into either the display or they're able
to integrate touch id into the side
button like they did in the ipad air so
here you can see what it looks like
between the mini
and the se obviously you have much more
screen real estate
because the screen stops here like
there's nowhere else for the screen to
go so here's the pro max in comparison
to the mini
so here's a size comparison of the boxes
this mini is very mini
well the phones are officially unboxed
you've seen size comparisons you've seen
the colors
and now it's time to test these out
okay now you're filming my phone okay
look at that
wow hi jen hey what's up how's it going
it's going
so right now what we're doing is we're
filming on two different phones i have
the pro max
jenna has the mini and we're just gonna
kind of film some content yeah
good luck good luck to you good luck to
you watch out for
uh tarantulas and snakes tarantulas and
snakes
[Music]
so
just do a little front-facing video here
on the 12 mini it's little
[Music]
so
so right now we are getting a time lapse
on the mini and the pro max
so windy that i had to jam this into
this rock
so that it would stay stable for our
time lapse
now we wait tyler we wait
how long does it take for the sun to set
i don't have reception
we're never gonna know 30 minutes i'm
[Music]
starving
me
[Music]
i was questioning my decision when i
ordered the pro max because the 12 pro
is such a perfect size
but the stabilization in this the 2.5 x
zoom
i made the right choice
[Music]
i can't control